hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
ever since i made the switch from being
a software engineer to
a content creator i realized my life
kind of revolves around different
deadlines
and that's because as a contract creator
most of the time i'm working on
different projects with different
companies and different people
and we're working on building something
towards a specific date
so naturally this has really tested my
procrastination
also just to be like completely honest
with you i just kind of feel like
these last two months i've been
procrastinating a lot
so as usual in my yuco form
i kind of took the time to just think
about that where is this procrastination
coming from
am i okay to be procrastinating what
really
is procrastination and what are
different ways that i can think about it
i mean the moral of the story is that i
realize that it's totally okay to
procrastinate but let me kind of walk
you through how i got there
before we get started i wanted to say
thank you to helix for sponsoring
today's video
so if you clicked on this video i'm
guessing that maybe you're
procrastinating right now and you
actually just want to lay down
like ellie and have a nice little nap in
bed which is where i want to talk to you
about the helix mattress
i've said this in many videos before but
sleep is so
important to me it's one of the things
that if i get enough of it then it
improves my quality of life
drastically and you know what when it
comes to sleep everybody's different and
helix knows that
so they created a sleep quiz that
matches you to your perfect mattress
based on your body type and sleep
preferences
so based on like your sleep positions
and like your preferred mattress
firmness then they have a unique
mattress fit for you
i personally sleep on my back a lot and
i kind of like a medium firm mattress
and so i was paired with the helix dusk
luxe
mattress in cal king literally though we
have two of these mattresses at home
one for our master bed and the other for
our guest room
myself and scott love sleeping on it and
every guest that we've had has said that
they slept like a baby on it
of course ellie also really likes
sleeping on the mattress too because
she sleeps on it every day with us the
best part is that the helix mattress
delivers right to your door for free and
it comes rolled up in a little box
that's pretty easy to set up
and if it makes you nervous to buy a
mattress that you haven't tried before
then they have a 100 night sleep trial
so that after three months if you don't
like the mattress then you can return it
to helix for a full refund
so visit the link below or go to
helixsleep.com
myuco for up to 200 off your mattress
and two free pillows
thank you to helix for sponsoring this
video and my sleep and now let's get
back to the video
so i think the story really starts at
school like everybody else
i was kind of a master procrastinator
especially in college
between midterms and essays and
programming assignments and other
quizzes and finals and stuff
i really only did things until i
absolutely had to
and i used to really beat myself up
about this because
like most students i kind of was just
like dreaming that i could be this
really studious version of myself
where i would do things as soon as
things are assigned or tasks were given
and not like the night before or a
couple hours before it was due
so yeah that dream of becoming a very
studious person
i feel like came and went sort of and
you know there are some folks who can
actually do this like do things as soon
as they're assigned
and i used to really admire those folks
and look up to them and i would really
try
but ultimately fail because i would end
up procrastinating but then when i
started work i think
all of that kind of changed because
there was a fundamental
change in the way that i worked because
in the tech industry there's all these
structures
and frameworks and methodologies for how
to work on big projects together and
completing tasks together as a team
basically it's all about just like
breaking big chunks of work into small
incremental steps
and then planning those small steps from
week to week in what we call
sprints and so basically like deadlines
more or less are self-imposed based on
what your estimates are for getting that
work done
working in this environment for many
many years really helped me to get good
at
breaking big things into small chunks
and then therefore being able to
understand the scope of the work better
which therefore really helped me to be
realistic
about what i can and cannot do given a
certain time frame
and so even when i made the jump into
content creation i more or less brought
this framework with me but also
creative work is inherently different
though because i can't plan for
inspiration to strike and i can't
plan for times that i'm going to be
ultra creative and other times where i'm
not going to be creative at all
and it's just all kind of hard and weird
and a lot of my work is very personal so
it doesn't work exactly the way that it
did before but i mean content creation
really is
a lot of the same stuff of taking big
things
breaking down into small chunks and then
planning it out so really i've just been
using this structure for getting work
done as a content creator
and it's kind of been working really
well and so in reflecting how that's
been going and how my workflow's going
i'm realizing like
i feel like i'm just so much more
comfortable with procrastination than i
used to be
i think it's just like i don't know i
feel more at peace with it like i'm not
as stressed out as i used to be
about assignments and midterms and stuff
and you know i've always had this
angling that procrastination and like
the energy associated with it
was a waste of energy in time frankly
because you know
noodling a bad about just like oh i
should be doing this paper but i'm not
doing this paper
but i should be doing this paper but i
don't want to do this paper it's just
like
then why not just not do the paper and
enjoy life and then do it later or just
do the paper you know
and this is kind of when it all dawned
on me i just have a very different
lens in which to look at procrastination
i'm looking at it from
a method of prioritization basically
we all have like important things to do
in life like i'm busy
you're busy there's like so many roles
that we take on
and stuff you're not gonna do some
things until it's actually really
important to
do those things i mean basically things
don't get done until they
have to because other priorities are
more pressing
so whether that's about like getting
enough sleep or eating well or
exercising or hydrating or working on
your personal relationship staying
connected with family
working on that essay you've been
meaning to organizing your spotify
playlist because now you can put them in
folders
hanging out with other people and your
loved ones and just like
going to the beach i don't know whatever
it might be you know
and i think it's just that i used to
think about all of that as oh i'm
procrastinating on this thing because i
didn't have a real
good structure or framework for how i
prioritize the things in my life
like i couldn't really trust that the
thing that i was doing right now was a
really high priority for myself
because at the time i was like this is
my most important priority and
everything else falls to the wayside
but that's not true because like we're
human and we have a lot of needs at once
and they all have to be attended to you
know and i always also thought that you
could just like
force things to be at the top of the
priority list by willing it
which you can sometimes but sometimes
you just
can't like you can't just do that so
honestly i think that now that i
understand what
my priorities are in life and what's
important to me
i've been able to prioritize the right
stuff
which really has given me the grace of
not feeling pressured about
procrastinating
i mean the key ingredient to all of this
too is that i just know myself so much
better now than i did before
like i know what i need i know what i'm
lacking i know what to do with the
energy that's flowing within me and how
to direct it towards the things that i
want to now
i know that i can also push when i
really need to and i can also take a
step back
and take a break and readjust when i
need to as well but i mean to be real i
still do procrastinate a lot i think i
just don't stress out about it as much
anymore
like my priorities and my bandwidth are
constantly changing all the time
so i'm constantly needing to readjust
how i get work done
and how do i prioritize the things in my
life and how do i take care of me and
everything else and you know sometimes
that means i procrastinate
on stuff but i am now a little bit more
forgiving because i know that if i miss
a deadline or if i'm neglecting a part
of my life
i know that it's usually for like a good
reason and a good reason to me sounds
something like oh i didn't have enough
energy that day
or there was something else in my life
that needed attention
or i just didn't have the creative juice
in me to bring that to life yet
i mean yes there are a lot of times
where i'm just like working until 10 pm
because i have a deadline
because you know what i'm not perfect
either and i'm not gonna get it right
all the time
but after that 10 pm deadline is done
then i'm probably gonna rest a bunch
i mean really i think it's all about
just like honoring my feelings and
validating it
listening to it and accepting it i guess
so yeah i don't know i think that
mindset has really helped me in thinking
about
procrastination in the mindset of
prioritization
i also have like a couple of other
mindset tips that i think
really helped me to not stress out about
procrastinating anymore
the first of which is really just that
like everything's gonna be okay
this is something that i think i've
realized over like
accumulating lots of experience and like
being older and stuff but like
everything's gonna be okay like
literally no deadline
or task or something in your life like
rarely is it ever gonna be so pressing
that it's gonna completely ruin your
life i guess
if you miss writing an email you know
for a day
like big whoop it's gonna be okay and i
think like parallel to that it's okay to
fail too like it's okay if you don't
meet the thing because maybe you fail
and then you learn
how to do it better next time the second
thing is just really having realistic
expectations of what you can
and cannot do we all like to think we're
super human and then we can get so much
work done or that
we think that other people can really
get a lot of work done but not
us and so we have these really
unrealistic high expectations for
ourselves but like
just figure out what is your capacity
and what are you comfortably able to do
and then stretch that little by little
over a long period of time
i mean i constantly think i'm superhuman
and my
to-do list is never ending but like it's
always really satisfying to me and i
feel really proud of myself
when i can actually complete the things
on my to-do list because i was realistic
with the time and energy i had to do
those things the third thing to help me
with this whole procrastination mindset
is really just to like show up and try
it this is something that i kind of
learned from my whole
creative journey i guess if you will
because there's a whole thing about like
showing
up to creativity like i think mindsets
and mental states are a really big
factor in whether we're able to do
things or not
but sometimes like real brain and the
body and the mind just need a little
kick start or a little warm up or
something
so if there's something that like i
really need to do or want to do or have
to do
and i'm just not really feeling it i'll
still kind of go through the motions of
doing it but for just like a small
amount of time
so usually what that looks like is
setting like a 25 minute pokemodora
timer and then just giving my whole
focus to that
and then you know honestly half the time
i'm like yeah okay i'm like i'm warmed
up now i'm ready to do this and then
there are other times where i'm just
like yeah i still don't want to do this
at all
in which case i'm like okay i gotta
honor that like i think i'm not ready
for it it's like you know at costco you
get samples and stuff and how are you
able to commit to a bulk size thing of
something
if you don't know if you're gonna like
how it tastes right now
and of course the last mindset shift
that i've had to help me not stress
out about procrastination is to know
thyself
i think this is a really important thing
to do especially after college because
it's kind of like
you're on your own you lead your life
however you want to do and so get to
know what you need out of life what you
want out of life
and then i think it makes it easier to
know how to prioritize your life
honor your priorities and not stress out
about things like i think
in doing that i've been able to forgive
myself of just like you know may you go
you're trying your best like i know you
are and you know maybe we can do a
little bit better next time but i'm
proud of you girl
so yeah it's totally okay to
procrastinate i don't think it's a bad
thing
it's just a natural thing that happens
so i hope that you know you're not
judging yourself too harshly for it
and i hope that this video has provided
a new perspective that at least you
might consider
in helping to reframe procrastination by
the way like none of my videos are meant
to be like you should do this or
you have to do x to achieve why like
all i can wish for is that you consider
my perspective
and you take what you want alright
everybody thank you so much for watching
if you'd like to see videos on other
topics related to like
my perspectives about life i guess then
let me know in the comments down below
make sure to subscribe if you'd like to
see more videos like this on my channel
and i'll see you next time take care bye